Well, can, can we actually talk about the suffering? Sure.
The darkest parts of writing a book.
So the let's let's go to the full Michael malice, Stephen King mode of,
uh, what are the darkest moments of writing this book and what is it?
Maybe start the white pill. What's the idea. What's the,
and what are your darkest moments around writing this book? So.
People are familiar with the red pill and the blue pill, the, the red,
the they're from the matrix,
the red pill is the idea that what is presented as fact by the corporate press
entertainment industry is in fact,
a carefully constructed narrative designed to keep some very unpleasant people
in power and everyone else under control.
And I guess like one of my expressions is you take one red pill,
not the whole bottle. Yeah.
Because at a certain point you think everything's a lie and then you're,
you're kind of no capacity for distinguishing truths.
You're full of good one liners. Well, thank you.
Yeah. I'm full of something. That's for sure.
And what I saw in this space is a,
of these red pilled people got very, um,
disheartened and cynical.
And one of my big heroes is Albert Kamoo and he said,
the worst thing is C and that's led something called the black pill,
which is the idea that, you know, it's, it's all it's, it's, it's just,
we're waiting for the end. It's and I,
I don't see it that way at all. And I'm like, all right,
I have to address this.
And not just with some kind of cheerleading, everything's gonna be great guys.
Here is why I am positive.
And not that I'm positive, the good guys you're gonna win,
but I'm positive that good guys can win.
And that's all you need because if your God forbid,
kid is kidnapped and there's a 10% chance that you can save them,
you're not gonna be like, whoa, I don't like those odds. This is your country.
This is your values. This is your family. Uh, I,
I think it's much more than 10%. And even if you lose,
you will take pride in that you did everything in your power to win.
So is there a good definition of good guys in.
The sense that the ones who wear white.
There's layers to this you're like modern day Shakespeare?
Is there a danger in thinking, um, uh, at all,
Hitler was probably pretty con confident that he
led a group.
Of good guys. Listen, if Hitler did anything wrong, why isn't he in jail?
<Laugh>.
Uh, my check friend thought of that joke. <laugh> he actually,
he says that his said, he goes, if Hitler's so bad, whyt he in that jail?
<laugh>.
That's a good point. He's probably still alive. Right? And look.
Yeah. <laugh> hopefully.
<Laugh> oh boy.
Two of the three people listening to this are very upset right now.